[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue en direct de l'umih
pour cette émission qui est consacré aux
relations entre les collectivités
locales départementales régionales et
avec l'état philippe petit espère y
bonjour on va on va rappeler après quels
seront les grands thèmes de démission
que je présente des invités alexandre
dublanche bonjour bonjour vous êtes vice
présidente de la région ile de france en
charge notamment du développement
économique et de l'innovation
jacques kossowski bonjour bonjour vous
êtes le maire de courbevoie et vous êtes
le président de l'union des maires de
des hauts-de-seine
pierrefonds bonjour vous êtes le
président d'union des pertes des
yvelines et et vous est aussi vice
président du conseil général des
yvelines je crois je parle sous le
contrôle de jeu coûte pas le seul
contrôle de pierre bédier bonjour
président du conseil départemental des
yvelines bonjour je suis censuré je n'ai
pas de vie annoncée pas normal on va
réparer ça et le président larcher
bonjour j'ai arraché président du sénat
bonjour on partage le micro avec le
président du conseil départemental
donc ça va très bien on va partager avec
philippe fli peut-être rappeler les
grands thèmes de cette émission oui on
va la découper en deux séquences pour
revenir un peu sur la thématique de la
de la table ronde sur les coopérations
un peu les leçons de la crise sanitaire
et des coopération entre les
collectivités donc régions départements
et communes
on est en train de sortir de cette crise
sanitaire et on va voir un peu c'est
coopération parfois inédites sur des
choses assez j'ai envie de dire même
parfois innovante de voir excuse
quelles leçons en tirer surtout est ce
que c'est ce type de partenariat va se
prolonger est-ce que même ça un pack une
nouvelle façon de travailler ensemble
donc ça sera le le premier temps et
second temps bon vous avez remarqué que
la campagne présidentielle commence
doucement à frémir donc on va parler de
la thématique de la décentralisation bon
pour l'instant peu présente mais de
savoir s'il ya votre avis elle est
importante j'ai une petite idée de vos
réponses et savoir si vous pensez que ce
thème l'un sera sera important la
campagne et on en profitera pour dire
quelques mots d'un projet de loi et au
sénat quito qui a été adopté au sénat et
qui arrive à l'assemblée en fin d'année
qui s'appelle 3ds je vous le détaillera
tout à l'heure et savoir effectivement
qu'est ce que vous pensez de ce texte
avec peut-être certaines insuffisances
alors auparavant je voudrais quand même
revenir y eut les élections régionales
et départementales il ya quelques
quelques semaines qui au vu quand même
une immense abstention 30 millions de
français ne sont pas déplacés pour pour
ces élections
quelles leçons vous tirez au fond de
cette ce qu'on pourrait appeler une
crise démocratique
bien payé
alors oui crise crise démocratique
qui s'aggrave puisque jusqu'ici les
élections locales étaient des élections
où la participation était supérieure
savait déjà commencé au moment des
élections municipales en bonus un
fléchissement donc on franchit là une
étape alors relativisons quand même
de deux idées que j'ai mais relativisons
parce que c'est quand même la crise
sanitaire qui a probablement impacter
sur la participation deuxièmement
profitons-en puisqu'on est en élection
présidentielle et qu on va en parler
tout à l'heure pour vraiment aborder la
troisième étape de la décentralisation
son voeu que les français participent il
faut qu'il comprenne comment ça marche
et pour qu'il comprenne comment ça
marche il faut revenir à ce principe qui
a fait la france c'est le principe
d'abord du socle que sont les communes
et ici nous sommes à l'université des
mers et ensuite on remonte avec le
principe de subsidiarité est comme ça on
sait que ona un interlocuteur principal
qui est le maire et les autres
collectivités sont lents soutien des
politiques qu'elles soient pour les
départements des politiques municipales
et pour moi pour les régions des
politiques départementales et bien
entendu se pose la question de
l'intercommunalité et je reste très
dubitatif sur cette invention de
l'intercommunalité je crois à
l'intercommunalité en province ou dans
les départements de grande couronne
lorsqu'il ya des villes centres je ne
crois pas à l'intercommunalité telle
qu'elle se pratique dans l'actuelle
métropole parisienne mais ce sont de
vastes débats que nous avons souvent
avec les nerfs alto séquanais oui
surtout que eux sont dans des
communautés d'agglomération au en plus
pris au marché justement est ce que
cette sorte de déni des démographes
démocratique vous pensez que c'est
plutôt justement
une indifférence ou un rejet d'abord
comme le président du conseil
départemental des yvelines c'est vrai
que nous avons eu la conjonction d'abord
de la crise sanitaire mais au fond
depuis dix ans et nous avons eu
progressivement une baisse de
participation n'oublions pas que les
élections législatives de 2010 est une
majorité de nos concitoyens
se sont pas déplacés pour voter et
choisir leurs députés je crois que ça
traduit l'état de défiance une grande
partie de nos concitoyens
et pourtant les seuls élus et nous
sommes dans l'université des maires des
yvelines et des hauts-de-seine les seuls
élus en lequel ils ont encore une vraie
confiance ce sont les maires
les maires adjoints et des conseillers
municipaux
crise de défiance parce qu'il ya une
crise du résultat et puisque nous
abordons la question de l'élection
présidentielle en tous les cas depuis
dix ans on a eu des engagements qui ne
se sont traduits par rien les gens
disent à quoi bon oui cette crise de
défiance aussi crise des gilets jaunes
ou du sentiment que mon nombre de nos
compatriotes de ne plus en quelque sorte
pouvoir participer à la table de la
république je l'avais écrit à françois
l'ordre 2015 quand il nous avait demandé
de réfléchir
claude bartolone alors président de
l'assemblée nationale et moi-même sur la
situation du pays et j'avais parlé d'une
france d'à côté d'une france qui se
sentaient à côté et bien c'est en grande
partie cette france d'à côté qui n'est
pas que la france rurale qui n'est pas
que la france des quartiers c'est
beaucoup dans des petites villes dans
des bourgs centres où il ya ce sentiment
et on le voit aussi dans une partie qui
se situe aux extrêmes de notre
département les yvelines où un
certainement le sentiment de ne plus
participer voilà oui c'est l'analyse on
a longtemps exprimé la france avec cette
cassure entre paris et la province on a
l'impression qu'aujourd'hui la vraie
cassure c'est entre le lui remet les les
cités et les grandes cités urbaines et
la france perd et veulent d'abord il ya
eu le sentiment sur les métropoles faut
qu'on soit clair le sentiment que quand
on était pas métropole souvenez-vous des
débats d'il ya cinq six ans on ne paie
pas mais moi je pense comme président du
sénat qui veut pas opposer les uns aux
autres on aimait il faut retrouver les
fondamentaux jeudi en regardant jacques
kossowski les fondamentaux dans les
hauts-de-seine comme en ariège si la
commune et c'est d'abord au niveau de la
commune que peut se reconstruire la
confiance
les vrais reconstructeurs de confiance
ça va être 36000 territoire qui
s'appelle la commune avec des élus qui
contribuent quelle que soit la taille de
la commune souvenez-vous crise des
gilets jaunes grand débat s'il n'y avait
pas eu les maires suis pas bien sûr psa
serait pas
meilleure c'est vous étiez vous l'aviez
dit vous même les maires ce sont les
élus à portée de sifflet et baroin disc
jockey vous n'êtes plus polie que ma
formule ils sont apportés d'engueulades
parce que c'est vrai parce que mettant à
portée d'engueulades ils ont la
confiance parce qu' ils répondent y
compris en disant d'accord pas d'accord
mais il reste les élus qui sont
atteignables en quelque sorte touchable
et comme dit baroin c'est les piliers de
la république mais justement je reviens
ce que disait pierre bédier alexandra du
plancher monsieur kossowski est ce qu'il
y aurait pas maintenant une nécessité de
simplifier quand même
l'organisation tous ses pouvoirs à est
vrai je rejoins ce qu'a dit le président
bédié on est dans une région en plus on
a le plus deschamps administratif avec
la métropole du grand paris avec deux
présidents qui s'entendent très bien et
encore heureux parce que qu'en serait-il
si demain ces deux présidents ne
s'entendait pas et allez dans direct des
directions différentes
mais effectivement je pense à créer une
incompréhension totale pour nos
concitoyens qui ne savent pas qui doit
rendre des comptes et à qui s'adressait
et ça se retrouve aussi peut-être dans
les élections même si je vois aussi et
je pense notamment en ile de france mais
dans d'autres régions qu'on a eu des
présidents depuis maintenant six ans qui
incarne beaucoup plus la région
qu'auparavant ils sont clairement plus
identifiée mais après effectivement il
non les concitoyens n'ont pas toujours
conscience que les régions et aussi
d'ailleurs les départements sont en
soutien dans tous les projets des maires
on le fait les maires le savent très
bien puisque aujourd'hui un maire doit
s'appuyer financièrement sur le
département et la région pour construire
des projets censés constituer on le voit
dans toutes nos communes mais ce n'est
peut-être pas encore bien à l'esprit de
tous nos concitoyens ce qui fait que
effectivement au moment des élections il
ya peut-être un désintérêt puis aussi
une moi je reviens il ya ulcos ville et
ses amis aussi une tentative de
nationalisation de ces élections aussi
par l'état en envoyant tout un tas de
ministre en parlant de sujets très
nationaux et ce qui fait que on est
complètement perdue on sait plus qui
fait quoi et peut-être qu'on se déplace
un petit peu moins pour les élections
moi je pense qu'une simplification des
compétences elle est essentielle faut
savoir qui fait quoi c'est aussi une
question d'efficacité c'est une question
d'attractivité aussi pour attirer des
investisseurs étrangers dans une région
comme la nôtre on est en compétition
constante avec d'autres régions
européennes mais et voir des d'autres
pays et donc quand il ya un parcours du
combattant ou même l'entrepreneur
l'investisseur ne sait plus à qui enfin
par quel biais passe et caetera et que
ça rallonge le processus il abandonne
donc pour de l'efficacité pour de la
simplification pour être plus agile je
pense qu'il faut cette clarification des
compétences on a trente fois plus de
collectivités qu'à londres france
vaincue au royaume-uni pas vraiment il
ya un vrai problème là dessus le fameux
millefeuille qui est particulièrement
dense en ile de france télécom ce qui
voulait dire un mot sur ce sujet oui
j'ai envie je reviendrai sur la crise de
défiance lorsque avant quand même là
qu'ovide les municipales attiré 60 à 65
% de votants c'est la commune qui a
bloqué un petit peu la situation ce qui
veut dire quoi ce qui veut dire que les
nerfs sont très populaires quelques
soient leurs tendances politiques et
jean très populaire parce que vous avez
tout à fait raison quand vous les
rencontres marché ou un canton alors ils
vous disent quelque chose et c'est pas
la même chose quand vous avez des mises
sous pression du public que vous voyez
une fois temps en temps c'est à dire que
vous si vous proposer quelque chose en
tant que maire et que ne le fait pas
dans six ans ce soit un doux puis ça se
voit tout de suite on y tient monsieur
mais on n'avait pas fait quand vous êtes
à haut niveau vous faites des
propositions et depuis dix ans ça
fonctionne pas ses patins quand on se
présente comme un projet de faire
quelque chose c'est ta différence est là
oui on voit les choses voilà on parlait
tout à l'heure des gilets jaunes les
gilet jaune qui sont arrivés j'ai écrit
personnellement au premier ministre de
l'époque et je lui ai dit la chose
suivante si vous voulez essayer de
mesurer la difficulté des gilet jaune il
faut passer par les préfets c'est les
seuls qui vont pouvoir être responsable
vis-à-vis des temps partiels
souvenez-vous ligier jaune il ya une
personne de responsable c'est ça le
problème vieilles personnes en si les
préfets dans chaque département avait
reçu les gilets no - rue un responsable
on n'a jamais répondu à la question on a
laissé pourrir les jets les jaunes en
dix ans et c'était quoi les jeunes gens
s'étaient le pouvoir d'achat il leur
manquait un pouvoir d'achat il avait
besoin de ça continue toujours et si
dans les élections on va en parler tout
à l'heure si on ne pense pas pouvoir
d'achat de nos élections ça fonctionnera
pas et légendes dépasseront encore moins
et un président de la république sera
élu avec 30 ou 40% des voix ce qui est
grave
j'ai cherché juste une des petites
questions mais je vais pas vous faire
l'injure non surtout j'ai eu même je
vais vous donner la parole tout de suite
sur justement les leçons de la crise
sanitaire
ambition de simplifier le millefeuille
administratif en tant que gaulliste vous
n'êtes pas pour la suppression du sénat
je n'a rien à voir
savez la france mais je vais pas aller
plus loin il ya que deux périodes où
elle n'a pas eu deux assemblées la
terreur et ça s'est terminé par la
création d'une assemblée pour en tirer
les conséquences le deuxième moment qui
fut un moment heureux la révolution de
1848 s'est achevée dans le coup d'état
du 2 novembre
1851 ou du prince-président ridant
j'aurais simplement rappelé que victor
hugo qui était un ennemi du bicamérisme
a dit
un pays gouverné par une seule assemblée
c'est
l'amer gouverné par l'ouragan
philippe
difficile de prendre la parole après sa
maison est facile après j'ai envie je
reviens sur la crise sanitaire et et les
leçons comme je vous disais tout à
l'heure c'est de voir un petit peu
ccc coopération que j'ai envie de dire
inédites et de choses nouvelles des
choses que vous étiez pas habitué à
faire je sais que c'est le cas notamment
avec le le département mais j'imagine e
siècle la région donc de revenir un peu
là dessus en sachant c'est moins sûr sur
la région mais il faut être honnête
aussi on sait que des fois il ya eu des
fonctionnements aussi par silos ce qu'on
a beaucoup reproché à l'état parce qu'on
sait que les relations n'ont pas été
comment dire fluide pour reprendre un
mot soft mais que des fois où j les
collectivités chacun
nager dans son couloir disons donc la
coopération qui a existé ça n'a pas
toujours été le cas donc je pense que
quand il ya des exemples c'est d'autant
plus intéressant d'en parler et comme je
vous dis de savoir est ce que ça peut
amener à même à travailler différemment
aujourd'hui et demain
bien fond oui bonjour avant qu'ils aient
la période que nous avons vécu sur la
pandémie mme et suite au gilet jaune
d'ailleurs est extrêmement intéressante
en terme de fonctionnement de l'autorité
publique et je croise à ce que nous
avons vécu avec que disait monsieur le
président du sénat sur la crise de
résultats parce qu'en fait l'analyse est
simple la parole politique et
décrédibiliser parce qu'elle n'est pas
efficace et donc nos concitoyens mettre
en parallèle l'absence de résultat et
une parole qui dit des choses mais qui
vit dans un autre monde et donc on sait
par les citoyens de ceux qui tiennent
cette parole là la pandémie c'était
simple on s'est retrouvés il faut avoir
vécu cette période en tant que maire on
s'est retrouvé dans un univers
complètement nouveaux ou tout était
désorganisé tout avec pendant notamment
le premier confinement l'incapacité de
la quasi totalité des pouvoirs publics à
répondre à la demande est beaucoup
d'injonction qui vous tombait est
d'abord un atout caché dans les greniers
des mairies si nous restait des masques
du h1n1 de madame bachelot et on avait
tous comme on jette rien dans les
mairies on avait des vieux cartons etc
les premiers masques qu'on a distribués
sachant qu'on les a même distribué aux
fonctionnaires d'état parce que l'état
n'était pas capable d'équiper ses
fonctionnaires et dans les zones cno
beaucoup y en ait beaucoup d'inconnues
randonnée aux hôpitaux là on s'est
aperçu qu'en fait en fonction des sujets
les résultats sont obtenus quand la
chaîne de commandement et la plus courte
possible et quand nous sommes dans la
proximité je dis pas pour tous les
sujets mais pour un certain nombre de
sujets c'est ça et le maire c'est quoi
ah bah c'est un centre de décision à son
niveau extrêmement proche du terrain et
c'est lui qui peut trancher les choses
et voyez la grande différence c'est que
quand un maire prend une décision
d'acheter des masques ou d'équipé on l'a
vu de façon flagrante pendant la
pandémie il prend la décision elle est
exécutée dans l'eure
quand on est dans un schéma différent le
temps que ça monte et que ça redescende
on est passé à la pandémie suivante et
donc on est dans un cadre où pour un
certain nombre de sujets il faut
préserver cette proximité et pour
préserver cette proximité ça signifie
qu'on est soi dans une vraie
décentralisation et que les communes
aient les moyens aussi de travail en
termes financiers mais c'est d'autres
sujets et donc les lois qui parle de
décentralisation même si elles peuvent
paraître technique sont essentiels pour
le fonctionnement de toute la société et
sur les relations avec les autres
collectivités vous êtes également vice
président du département séduit des
j'imagine est là et la région je vous
poserai aussi la question après mais
heureusement que le département et la
région était là parce que je rappelle
quand même que les premiers achats
équipements etc venez de la région et du
département et heureusement qu'on se
connaît qui a cette proximité aussi
géographique parce qu'il arrive des
moments où c'est pas le process
administratifs qui joue c'est la
connaissance des individus bon alors ton
vit pas tout le temps des périodes aussi
chaotique mais le partenariat il est
bien réelle et je peux vous dire est
tous les maires ici peuvent lui garantir
que nous avons été soutenus de façon
extrêmement efficace par les
départements et la région ile de france
et ce qui a permis de faire face à la
situation y remédier justement sur cette
situation est-ce qu'on n'a pas touché la
lourdeur administrative de l'état et le
fait que les collectivités locales les
départements les régions peuvent aller
ce que comme vous le disiez plus vite
parce que on décide plus vite ça va plus
vite il n'y a pas besoin de toute cette
administration qui met souvent des
bâtons dans les roues avec les
meilleures intentions du monde
d'ailleurs peut-être
tom département des yvelines
le problème de la santé publique était
posée avant la pandémie et c'est
d'ailleurs pourquoi le département a
lancé un grand programme de financement
de maison médicale et j'avais à cette
occasion déjà dit que nous étions
volontaires nous le département des
yvelines dans le cadre d'une troisième
étape de la décentralisation
pour expérimenter la compétence santé
alléchant départemental nous avons une
compétence santé partiel on s'occupe de
la petite enfance nous avons cette
action sur les maisons médicales
les hôpitaux enfin lé groupement
hospitalier nous sollicitent assez
régulièrement pour acheter du matériel
performant donc je pense qu' il est
temps maintenant d'imaginer à l'échelon
départemental ce transfert de la
compétence santé est en tout cas les
yvelines sont vraiment volontaire je
précise que pendant la pandémie donc ça
n'a fait que renforcer mon sentiment ça
a plutôt bien fonctionné du côté de
l'état neil de france parce que la rs l'
agence régionale de santé l'intelligence
de s'appuyer sur ces unités
départementales et la relation entre le
conseil départemental le préfet de
département est la seule agence
départementale de santé enfin l' agence
régionale et son
sa représentation des barres de rire ça
a été extrêmement fluide et c'est ce qui
a permis à mon sens d'enrayer la
pandémie qui partait très très très
sévèrement dans le département puisque
les le virus était rentré dans les
maisons de retraite et c'était une
hécatombe donc il a vraiment fallu
prendre des décisions courageuses et
rapide et cette chaîne de commandement
très courte avec cette fluidité a permis
de répondre efficacement
on en parlera aussi et que le projet
leur 3ds qui effectivement pas
suffisamment lundi le sénat mais d'avoir
des transferts de compétences donc
peut-être là la même question que je
posais à pierrefonds à jacques kossowski
je voudrais parole après je vous promets
sur un peu ce bilan un peu de la crise
sanitaire et la coopération avec les
autres niveaux de collectivités alors je
ne suis pas il choisit du conseil
départemental
mais j'ai quand même en parler nous
avons eu la chasse passe bien que le
département collombat peut plus rien
n'est jamais perdu tout peut arriver un
jour
non ce qui est faux bien passé que les
départements dans les hauts-de-seine
comme dans les yvelines et bien de le
dire on s'est vraiment bien appuyé
dessus on a travaillé nous avons fait un
petit peu différemment non pas dans les
départements de san dans nos territoires
j'ai un territoire si vous voulez de 11
communes et nous avons passé nous la
première commande six cent mille masques
eu tout de suite on a débloqué un
million d'euros et on est allé chargé
sur 1000 masques parce que sinon même
dans les écoles il n'avait pas de masque
donc c'est nous qui a remporté le
personnel soignant n'avait pas de masque
si nous qui avons planté de masques et
après ils ont entendu le département a
travaillé avec nous et puis on a fait
aussi appel à la région je crois qu'on a
cette chance et comme le disait tout à
l'heure alexandra on a la chance d'avoir
le département à la région je dirais
très jeune dans une même sensibilité ça
nous permettra ensemble et on peut
s'appeler on peut se voir oui mais c'est
peut-être une exception
dans cette suite aura peut-être il en va
de votre part ça ne devrait pas être une
exception quand partie moment on est élu
on est élu pour quelqu'un on est habile
sur le peuple donc il doit pas y avoir
d'exception c'est peut-être que dans
certains départements certaines régions
des exceptions mais ces gens là ne sont
pas à leur place normalement quelle que
soit la sensibilité on est élu pour
apporter quelque chose enfin j'ai
nettement et c'est pour ça que en
premier c'est toujours les maires et
puis le maire font appel à leur
département à la région mais vraiment
pendant cette pandémie si les
différentes intermédiaire la région
département n'a pas dit elle a les nerfs
croyez moi les français on serait très
mal c'est grâce à cette coopération
qu'on a pu continuer à travailler merci
à l'ex trader alexandre gandou blanche
côté justement région on a vu que les
régions étaient vraiment aux
avant-postes sur la crise sur les
masques effectivement toutes les
collectivités ont acheté des masques
mais effectivement les régions était qu
un très très présent et au delà de cette
question là quelle coordination avec les
autres collectivités est-ce qu'il ya
d'autres sujets sur lequel vous avez des
coopérations mais j'ai envie dire même
des mutualisations et et en est encore
difficile pour la presse que justement
ça laissera des est-ce que ça laissera
une autre une autre façon de travailler
je précise quand même que même quand on
n'est pas du même bord politique avec le
département au travail très bien
heureusement heureusement de l'île de
france bien évidemment c'est vrai que
je pense nos concitoyens l'ont aussi vu
l'agilité des collectivités dans
s'écrire l'exemple des masques et
tellement révélateur effectivement on a
une capacité en 4 jours à la région a
monté une chaîne d'approvisionnement
affrété des avions pour aller en chine
grâce à la communauté chinoise
ile-de-france pour amener ils ont pas
été réquisitionnés sur l'état remarque m
sinon les racks et figurez vous que les
10 millions premier masque reçues ont
été à la rs donc c'est les régions qui
ont fourni à la rs les premiers masques
et assez ubuesque
on a aussi eu des situations comme le
disait mon maire et président de l'umih
on a dû équiper dans les policiers
nationaux alors avec parfois des
réticences de l'état ce qu'on le fasse
d'ailleurs ce qui était un peu délirant
mais donc cette agilité on l'a vu aussi
sur des lits de réanimation on a été en
capacité très rapidement d'aller
chercher des fonds européens on critique
souvent l'europe des fonds européens
pour équiper 500 lits de réanimation
éphémère dans les hôpitaux d'île de
france qui a été évidemment très utiles
etc on l'a fait sur le plan économique
je pense le travail avec les
collectivités
la proximité la connaissance des
territoires étaient essentiels on n'a
pas arrêté pendant cette crise de faire
des réunions par exemple par département
évidemment ne parlait pas de la même
chose à la défense où on parlait
beaucoup du télétravail qu'est ce qu'on
faisait et caetera et en seine-et-marne
dans les zones rurales et les problèmes
ne sont pas les mêmes les solutions ne
sont pas les mêmes et c'est ce que nous
on était tous collectivement on faisait
remonter de façon très agile très je
pense rapide avec aussi les partenaires
les consulaires etc donc ça ça a été un
travail collectif qui a permis de créer
je pense les bons dispositif en
complément de l'état il ne fallait pas
ajouter de la complexité à ce qui était
déjà une situation extrêmement durs à
vivre pour tout le monde toujours venir
en complément de l'état sur des
dispositifs économiques également pour
ne pas perdre davantage les petits
commerçants les petits restaurateurs etc
et aussi et je trouve pour répondre à
votre deuxième question qu'est ce qui
restera on a on a tous pensé
or de la carte off the box comme on dit
en anglais
réfléchir autrement par exemple on a
monté des dispositifs je pense au fond
résilience qu'on a tous financés on a
réussi en pleine municipal donc avec un
contexte politique compliqué à monter un
fonds d aide aux petits commerçants
restaurateurs ou chaque collectivité
chaque territoire d'île de france a
participé de la mairie de paris et la
métropole et dans paris avec grâce à ce
travail où effectivement on travaille
pour nos territoires avec la
connaissance de nos territoires et ça je
pense que cette proximité aussi avec les
intercommunalités
ça restera avec une adaptabilité à
chaque chaque territoire vraiment c'est
ce qui ressortira de cette crise je le
pense et je l'espère oui ça pouvait déjà
existé avant mais là ça a été poussé
cette passoire bien sûr tout un tas de
sujets que ce soit la santé l'économie
etc mais comme un marché non justement
quelles leçons vous vous tirez de cette
répartition des pouvoirs que nous a
peut-être appris la crise sanitaire il
ya peu après tout peut-être des bons
côtés qu'il faut qu'il faut tirer de
cette crise moi je vais essayer d'avoir
un regard nationale peut briller demain
je serai avec les maires du rhône la
semaine prochaine avec les maires de la
région paca j'étais avec les maires de
vendée la semaine passée au fond
l'observation c'est que les
collectivités territoriales ont
travaillé en convergence et en
complémentarité
jamais en concurrence quel que soit
j'allais dire la répartition dans une
démocratie des diversités
le second des sujets c'est que
les collectivités territoriales il faut
bien que l'état se le mettre dans la
tête ne sont pas des opérateurs de
l'état les collectivités territoriales
ne sont pas des opérateurs de l'état
mais ce ne sont pas non plus des ennemis
de l'état et nous avons besoin d'un état
territorial renforcée est présent voilà
pourquoi avancer ça veut dire quoi
encore six à venir un préfet qui a
autorité sur ses services et que nous
n'ayons pas des agences diverses et
variées qui s'occupent les unes
d'énergie d'hôtes d'habitat des
troisièmes d'environnement qui échappent
à l'autorité du préfet
deux départements voilà pourquoi la
déconcentration à des quelque chose
d'important n'opposons pas l'état
territorial et les territoires
n'opposons pas non plus l'état central
au territoire mais je le redis les
collectivités territoriales ne sont pas
des agents de l'état ça veut dire que
derrière il faut en tirer parce que la
pandémie
est la rochefoucauld qui disait qu il
n'est nulle difficultés qu'un homme ou
une femme d'esprit d'esprit depuis se
transformer en succès la prenons
l'exemple de la crise de gilet jaune
comme de la pandémie pour transformer
assez profondément me semble-t-il
le mode d'organisation de notre pays
revenons quarante ans après sur le sujet
de la décentralisation
la déconcentration
de l'état avec un état central qui
s'occupe du régalien pardonnez moi je
vais mettre les pieds dans le plat
jamais jamais le pays n'a été autant
verticale au point d'ailleurs que pour
sauver la prévenue en retrait puis sauvé
marseillan n'a rien trouvé de mieux
avant-hier que de nommer un préfet pour
chargé de gérer marseille en lieu et
place des mères et de la présidente de
la métropole bien mais je reviens sur ce
que vous disiez tout à l'heure ben ali
et des compétences du département en
matière de santé
concrètement ça veut dire quoi ça
voudrait dire quoi
ça veut dire que le département devrait
avoir la responsabilité
budgétaire des hôpitaux le pido pas 15
hôpitaux alors naturellement tout ça
doit faire l'objet
d'un grand transfert fiscal
ce qui est encore un autre sujet puisque
c'est pas avec nos budgets qu'on
pourrait presque mais nous pourrions
comme sa portée la carte hospitalière
les moyens hospitaliers toute la
médecine publique
alors il ya une soudaine il ya une
deuxième deuxième secteur où nous
revendiquons là aussi le transfert c'est
le parent pauvre de la médecine
d'aujourd'hui c'est la médecine scolaire
il n'y a plus de médecine scolaire en
france je demande donc il serait logique
que nous ayons la médecine scolaire
j'évoquais tout à l'heure la médecine
qui existait déjà qui était celle de la
petite enfance alors bien entendu il
faut une coordination à l'échelon
national
parce qu'il ya des départements qui ne
sont pas en capacité de pouvoir porter
cela est donc l'échelon national avec
l'échelon régional doit pouvoir être en
coordination et un appui mais encore une
fois la proximité produit du résultat
c'est ce qu'on dit depuis le début et si
on veut sortir de la crise démocratique
il faut que nos concitoyens puissent
savoir à qui ça va être aujourd'hui
si vous n'avez pas de médecin dans votre
commune vous engueuler le maire mais le
maire n'a pas libre rien n'a pas de
moyens d'agen et donc il faut pouvoir
donner ces moyens d'agir au maire et
pour leur donner les moyens d'agir il
faut qu'ils aient comme on dit en bon
français le back office des départements
qui viennent leur apporter l'aide
logistique
on peut aussi fort mais on peut
participer à la formation peut prendre
en charge
la
l'installation de médecins on a une
université commune avec le département
des hauts-de-seine une université de
médecine cette université de médecine à
la des internes on pourrait très bien
imaginer que nous financent les études
de ces internes en contrepartie de quoi
il devrait y installer une vraie des
milliers d'heures dans les zones
blanches dans les autres double
enveloppe soleau on sent on connaît les
ont si on connaît le terrain d'essai
mieux les réalités que quelque chose
pour saisir et de paris quoi on peut
faire du du détail là où la machine
étatique ne fait que du nivellement et
du nivellement par le bas
oui juste un mot parce que gérard
larcher vous parliez d'un état crée très
verticale et durant la crise sanitaire
on l'a vu à plusieurs reprises
je me souviens l'un des laboratoires
d'analysé au moment où effectivement
pour faire des tests c'était quand même
pour le moins compliquée et le temps
qu'il a fallu pour qu'on autorise les
départements et utiliser leurs
laboratoires quitté quand même une
ressource quand même bien pratique là
est ce que c'est je pense que vous allez
abondé dans ce sens là est-ce que c'est
pas une illustration de parce qu'il a
fallu j'ai plus la durée mais il un
salon de deux semaines un moment où le
temps était étaient comptés et là
c'était une ressource tout à fait quitté
qui tombait à point nommé dix emplois
rapport aux tests si on écrivait la
liste des dysfonctionnements la
difficulté qu'on a eu à engager nos
sapeurs pompiers alors que les sapeurs
pompiers pouvaient tout à fait il y
avait des médecins qui pouvait aller
faire les tests dans les maisons de
retraite le temps qu'on année
l'autorisation
les vétérinaires qui était tout à fait
disposé à donner un coup de main les
vétérinaires on pouvait les mobiliser
ils n'attendaient que ça nous on savait
mais le temps s'était expliqué tout à
l'heure le président de l'umih le temps
que ça remonte au sommet et le monde
mais qu'on prenne et que ça redescende
bas il se passe un mois le temps et le
manque de confiance norge peux vous
raconter pour les labos vétérinaire et
je mets au défi j'ai appelé le président
de la république et le premier ministre
pour qu'on débloque parce que nous
avions besoin parce qu'on était ainsi
dans un système qui avait changé en 2013
et c'est
je reprends les mots du président de la
république sont toutes depuis que j'ai
un peu mince y cdta obèses donc quand
vous voyez qu'un président du sénat
actionné par le président de l'ordre des
vétérinaires
actionné par les présidents de
départements
proches au téléphone mais dit ça n'est
pas possible et d'ailleurs edouard
philippe dans son livre raconte que
c'est sans doute une des plus grandes
difficultés qu il ait eue c'est à
soulever cette espèce de mastodontes qui
ne voulaient pas s'adapter et je crois
que c'est un des sujets genre voit ce
que dit pierre faux sur la proximité qui
est un sujet essentiel
l'anecdote que je vous dit où la
retrouverez dans le dire edouard
philippe mais je peux vous l'assurer
mais de parler d'un manque de confiance
ça vous paraît trop fort
de parler de manque de confiance de la
part des services de l'état ça vous
paraît trop fort parce qu'ils nous
considèrent comme des opérateurs et nous
ne sommes pas des opérateurs de l'état
je n'ai jamais oublié que j'ai été maire
pendant trois décennies et moi je fais
confiance au maire ça veut pas dire
qu'on est toujours d'accord mais c'est
d'abord la proximité numéro un
vouliez intervenants ce que je voulais
dire c'est que ce qui est intéressant
cantonnés dans des périodes de crise
c'est de voir comment notre système
notre organisation résiste aux chocs et
ce qui va ce qui ne va pas donc là on a
vécu on continue un peu le vivre de
façon moins intense une période de crise
il faut regarder donc dans notre système
français ce qui coince et s'ils
connaissent pas et je voudrais ajouter
aussi que les maires ont aussi besoin
d'un état local qui soit réelle on est
plusieurs à voir quelques mandats
derrière nous et nous avons connu des
dde à l'époque qui était efficace des
services préfectoraux qui était
compétent nombreux etc on a vu
progressivement dépérir l'état local et
7 de dépérissement des tas local est
aussi un problème et quand le président
bédié dit heureusement que dans l'île de
france les ars départementale au
fonctionner je rappelle quand même que
le schéma d'organisation c'était une ars
régionale et donc on a cru à un moment
rs me disent mais on a cru un moment à
rs c'est un moment qu'il fallait monter
sans arrêt et on s'est éloigné du
terrain et on a aussi besoin de préfets
qui ont à leur disposition des moyens
humains financiers pour travailler et je
crois qu'un des problèmes de
fonctionnement la société française
c'est d'avoir cru c'est comme la
mondialisation c'est d'avoir cru que en
faisant ailleurs c'était bien meilleur
qu'en faisant ici maintenant on est en
train de regarder au travers de la
lecture de cette pandémie qu'au fond on
a besoin aussi que les choses se fassent
sur nos territoires alors peut-être
qu'on va passer au dernier thème de
cette émission justement à l'orée des
élections présidentielles qu'elle serait
on va revenir sur la 3ds dans un instant
mais quels seraient les demandes au foot
pourriez faire au prochain ou la
prochaine président de la république
au niveau de la décentralisation au
niveau de la répartition des pouvoirs
voit là dessus je pense qu'il y avait
tous les maires ici pour vous dire la
même chose j'imagine on a aujourd'hui
d'aider un certain nombre de
problématiques existe mais il y en a une
qui est quand même à me semble-t-il
majeur c'est que dans un budget communal
ya une partie dépenses mais il ya aussi
une partie des recettes et jaur abord je
renvoie à l'article 72 de la
constitution qui dit il faut une
autonomie des collectivités locales
c'est donc à l'autonomie elle porte sur
le choix de la dépense mais elle doit
porter également sur
le volet recettes pas peut-être sur la
totalité et moi je trouve que
l'évolution de ces dernières années
notamment la disparition de la taxe
d'habitation a fait que les conseils
municipaux ont perdu la maîtrise des
recettes et donc sont dépendants de
l'état et de mécanismes de compensation
honnêtement que personne ne comprend et
donc on est là dans un déséquilibre qui
va probablement falloir réparer il ya
d'autres choses mais je pense que
d'avoir un projet présidentiel également
sur le fonctionnement des territoires
pris les articulations dans le sens de
la décentralisation d'une
décentralisation responsable c'est
quelque chose d'important site c'est une
vieille question je veux dire depuis les
lois defferre on ya eu beaucoup de lois
quand même si on a sur la
décentralisation sur la régionalisation
et on a l'impression que c'est un peu
que le rocher de sisyphe il faut
toujours remonter les choses
la loi trois décennies à alès signifie
simplification ça serait peut-être bien
d'arriver à mettre en place des
mécanismes financiers ou de compétences
que quelqu'un qu'on prenne un je suis
pas sûr qu'ils aient quelqu'un dans la
république qui les comprennent
aujourd'hui qui avait dit non là dessus
sur sur ce besoin de décentralisation et
la difficulté ou font de leur mettre une
vraie en place
c'est vital aujourd'hui la france est à
la croisée des chemins
notre pays est surendetté notre pays est
en panne de dynamisme économique notre
pays doutent de lui même je suis
profondément convaincu que seule la
décentralisation parce qu'elle peut
permettre de clarifier les choses peut
sauver
pardonnez moi de dire les choses avec
peut-être grandiloquence mais peut
sauver la france qu'on aime l'état doit
se concentrer sur ce que nous ne pouvons
bien entendu pas faire c'est à dire la
sécurité extérieure les affaires
étrangères
la sécurité intérieure pour l'essentiel
mais aussi en partenariat avec avec les
élus donc tout ce qu'on appelle le
régalien et la justice bien évidemment
qui manquent de moyens pour le reste
tout est possible et tout est possible
avec les territoires et tout marchera
mieux avec les territoires mais il faut
aussi sortir de cette idée très
française du jardin à la française c'est
à dire qu'on voudrait que ce soit pareil
dans la creuse que l'art est partout ce
n'est pas possible les ressources ne
sont pas les mêmes les territoires la
géographie l'histoire ne sont pas les
mêmes et donc il faut accepter cela il
faut il faut bien entendu l'idée n'est
pas plutôt la région que le département
plutôt le département que la région je
vais vous donner un exemple est ce que
c'est normal qu'aéroports de paris soit
toujours géré par l'état est ce que
c'est normal que la régie autonome des
transports parisiens la ratp
son président directeur général soit
décidée en conseil des ministres ce sont
des structures qui doivent être gérés à
l'échelon régional de même à l'échelon
départemental pardonne-moi alexandra est
ce que c'est logique que demain on
propose le transfert des routes
nationales vers la région alors que ce
qui en dehors de l'état ont un service
de voirie ce sont des départements il
vaut mieux que ce soient les
départements même si nous devons nous
coordonner à l'échelon régional et c'est
donc cette grande décentralisation que
j'appelle de mes voeux et je ne
l'appelle pas de mes voeux parce que je
crois que les élus locaux sont
privilégier pour je ne sais quelles
raisons électorales je l'appelle de mes
voeux parce que j'aime la france que je
vois ce pays englué ce pays des cadets
c'est un joli mou se paye en décadence
et jeu et je rêve que ce pays se
redresse et seule la décentralisation
peut le permettre gérard larcher vous
parliez de retour de la verticalité
comment on explique ça au fond parce que
c'est vrai qu'il ya cette grande
aspiration à la décentralisation et
c'est vrai que dans l'exercice réel du
pouvoir on revient quand même vers la
verticalité je pense que la tentation de
la verticalité n'a pas commencé il ya
quatre ans et demi fait une dizaine
d'années que nous avons assisté à cette
recentralisation
cette recentralisation elle a commencé
d'abord par l'asphyxié financière des
territoires est-ce que je dois rappeler
que entre 2012 et 2017 nous avons perdu
12 milliards de dotation globale de
fonctionnement
qu'à départements comme les yvelines a
quasiment perdu 80% à 90% pardonnez-moi
de sa dotation globale de fonctionnement
quand on nous retire en plus pour les
collectivités le levier de la décision
fiscale sur la taxe d'habitation et la
taxe d'habitation
vélo qui ont ce matin avec des maires et
avec des maires ruraux
la taxe d'habitation c'est pas
simplement un revenu si aussi un lien
entre les citoyens et les services
qu'apporte la commune vous avez demain
des communes où plus de 50 % des
citoyens de contribueront plus du tout
au fonctionnement des services de la
commune ça veut dire qu'un jour on aura
plus de liens de citoyenneté nous aurons
des consommateurs et non plus des
citoyens et ça pour la république c'est
absolument terrible voilà pourquoi je
vous le dis il faudra un vrai changement
il va falloir comme de 10 et pierrefonds
que nous retrouvions l'autonomie
financière
défini dans la constitution
la constitution a déjà dit
l'organisation de la république est
décentralisée
il faut qu'on en tire les conséquences
et la part d'autonomie financière qui
n'est pas de faire n'importe quoi il va
falloir qu'on la retrouve suivant un
principe que l'association des maires de
france avait ainsi défini dans
territoire unis parce que je rappelle
qu'on travaille ensemble les
départements les régions
les communes en lien d'ailleurs avec le
sénat dans tous les groupes politiques
parce que nous pensons vraiment que
c'est à partir des territoires que ce
peut se reconstruire la confiance il n'y
a pas que les territoires qui compte
l'état central c'est quelque chose de
tout à fait essentiel mais je rappelle
l'importance des territoires une
meilleure coordination entre les
territoires et et l'état malheureusement
le temps qui nous est imparti v vouliez
dire un juste un petit bout alors mais
rapide ou est rapide juste sur la
confiance on était récemment être le
président larcher au congrès des régions
de france et c'est vrai qu'on entend on
manque parfois de confiance malgré un
discours toujours très constructif des
régions quel que soit le bord politique
pourquoi ces questions de compétence
c'est pas une question de pouvoir c'est
une question d'efficacité
je lui demande ce qu'on a vu pendant la
crise que le sur les vaccins avec une
uniformité sur tout le territoire qui
avait détruit les régions plus touchées
que les autres c'était complètement
absurde et sa l'état ne sait pas faire
c'est pour ça qu'il a besoin des
collectivités et c'est pour ça que il
faut laisser du lest et ne pas nous
considérer juste comme des tiroirs
caisses sans nous donner les moyens
accessoirement mais vraiment faire
confiance pour qu'on soit à gilles au
quotidien auprès de nos concitoyens les
convertibles rapidement en cinq minutes
je crois qu on n'a jamais vu un pays
aussi fracturé qu'aujourd'hui il jamais
donc il ya vraiment quelque chose à
faire quand peu présent dans le public
sera le prochain ou le nouveau il faut
faire quelque chose on peut pas
continuer à voir comme ça les français
aujourd'hui ne sont plus ensemble il
n'est plus l'heure pays ensemble chacun
regarde son propre tout et ça c'est pas
normal il ya quelque chose très
important et deuxièmement quand on a des
transferts de l'état il faut aussi qu'on
est en sueur financiers allianz il le
disait suffit pas toujours de faire
simplement ce que l'état et c'est ce qui
nous a manqué aussi c'est ce qui nous
manque et puis essayons de l'essai de
faire confiance aux collectivités
locales
omer il s'agirait eux eux ils ont besoin
d'avoir un budget en équilibre et paca
d'état s'ils étaient obligés d'avoir un
budget en équilibre croyez moi et
beaucoup de choses qui changerait et un
moment là vayssié de mettre la
constitution quand j'étais député salah
pas été plus loin et cette question des
répartitions des pouvoirs c'est aussi
des visions de la france donc ça sera
sans doute au centre des débats
présidentiels merci merci beaucoup
d'avoir participé à cette émission merci
[Musique]